aurillac ville la plus sportive de
france en 1986 c'est le titre que vient
de lui décerner notre confrère l'équipe
un concours annuel qui récompense la
ville qui a fait le plus d'efforts en
matière d'équipements sportifs mais
aussi qui compte le plus grand nombre de
pratiquants
c'est à l'unanimité qu'aurillac a été
désignée par un jury pour succéder à
angers reportage 2000 planches et
jean-marc robin aurillac 65 clubs
sportifs 42 sport pratiqué plus de douze
mille licenciés
c'est à dire plus d'un habitant sur
trois parmi toutes les activités c'est
sans conteste le rugby qui au plan
national est le meilleur ambassadeur de
l'image sportive de la préfecture du
cantal avec la présence du stade
aurillacois au plus haut niveau de la
compétition
cependant le sport le plus populaire ou
le plus pratiqué demeure comme presque
partout le football
quant au nombre de licenciés la palme
revient cette fois au tennis avec près
de quinze cents joueurs
aurillac une ville multisports consacré
à l'unanimité pour 86 comme la ville la
plus sportive de france
une distinction certes méritée au
préalable grâce à la présentation d'un
dossier et qui récompense surtout la
densité des installations et l'esprit
sportif
c'est le sport mis à la portée de tous
les aurillacois que chacun puisse y
trouver son compte aussi bien le sport
de compétition que le sport de loisir et
de ce côté-là je crois qu aurillac a
fait un énorme effort pour que tout le
monde puisse faire ce sport dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
il croit qu'il y à une demande de la
population il y a une volonté des élus
moi même ainsi que plusieurs élus nous
pratiquons régulièrement des sports et
nous pensons que l'activité sportive
fait partie de l'éducation de l'homme
donc nous souhaitons avoir le plus
d'enfants possible dans nos écoles de
sport nous en avons de 2700 et nous
souhaitons que la pratique sportive
contribuer à faire des adultes équilibré
égaux
ainsi sept fils international de bicross
en cours de finition est l'une des
dernières réalisations communales et
répond justement à l'attendre des jeunes
athlètes ailleurs sept fils à qui ira
peut-être en 88
les championnats de france de la
spécialité en tout cas force est de
reconnaître que cette ville consacre
depuis plusieurs années un budget
conséquent à l'investissement et
l'entretien de son outil sportif aux
multiples facettes
il ya d'abord le budget de
fonctionnement c'est-à-dire l'aide aux
associations sportives ça représente 7 %
du budget total de fonctionnement de la
ville d'aurillac
et puis il ya le budget d'investissement
c'est à dire les constructions de
gymnase des aménagements de terrain etc
cela représente aussi 7 à 8% du budget
d'investissement de la ville d'aurillac
donc pourcentage tout à fait important
en faveur de l'activité sportive
songez par exemple que depuis huit ans
eh bien nous avons plus de 2 milliards
de centimes d'investissement sportif au
regard de l'or il ne faut pas s'étonner
des quelque 60 titres de champion
d'auvergne récolté rien qu'en sport
individuel pendant la saison 85 86 e
delà de ces résultats la priorité
aujourd'hui est de gérer les
installations plutôt que de penser à de
nouveaux projets sur pjak
rien dans les trois ans qui viennent
rien d'autre que le maintien de
l'existant qui est déjà considérable
puisqu'il vient d'être consacrée et si
vous ne deviez pas à présenter votre
dossier ce qu'on serait venu vous voulez
ça y est je ne passe pas je suis sûr que
personne serait venu voir si aurillac
est une ville très sportive
en tout cas ici l'objectif avoué de
faire grimper encore le nombre des
pratiquants car après tout si le travail
c'est la santé
alors le sport c'est peut-être bien l'
équilibre de nous avons tous besoin